un ragazzo sul rosso madonna veramente
normalmente le persone siano in un certo
modo così io io no no no no non ti ci
sono gli alberi no vi faccio vedere
com'è andata la giornata prima di
arrivare a questo punto ragazzi guarda
c'è la gente normale nel mondo a sciare
in un certo modo io vado a sciare mentre
esco di casa con la merenda
perché questa è la merenda mi porto
appresso a bottiglia d'acqua brownie e
delle calze in mano quindi adesso
ragazzi stiamo aspettando leo che ha
appena arrivato tra l'altro corso ball
idonei al martedì come si lavano la
macchina nuova
[Risate]
[Musica]
pensiamo nella macchina davanti sto
riprendendo la macchina dietro c'è
starci agli studi la morte
ciao pietro faccio il saluto ciao pietro
baffa sorella ragazzi è morto anche
tutor è morto tudor e morto sasha
fantastico questo viaggio ti stai
divertendo pietro si sta divertendo ora
lo sguardo di chi si diverte pietro
grazie a dire sveglio e saranno essere
addormentato lui era un problema ragazzi
non ho mai visto un chupa chupa costare
così tanto
porca [ __ ]
perché per arrivare a questo posto di
montagna ci vogliono 3 ore e mezza ma
non è neanche tanto questo problema
problema è che macchine si pose si
arriva domani ma non me ne frega un
cazzo è tardi nel signore oggi sasha ci
spiega come mangiare un budino classico
[Musica]
tutto chiaro grazie che ne sai cosa la
superficie diventa per mano va bene così
anche se un partito che l'autore sera
con lapo che se vorranno questo video
ora quanta roba è tutta per te la puoi
non voglio fare quello che portassi che
mi stanno tutti andando la direzione
opposta quindi oggi e godzilla siamo
arrivati ragazzi ci aveva messo una vita
e mezza si e indovinate chi è lui
vincete un premio sarà difficile da
indovinare chi è questo ragazzo comunque
ma che cazzo ma che quello nella roccia
ma cosa vuol dire perché ti incastrato
una valigia dentro dentro dentro il
tetto
io adesso giro la visuale voi non ridete
ok voi non ridete non avete riso vero
che se non siete brutte persone di
staccare a sotto vivrà tutto il quarto
per tutti non ho mai fatto snowboard e
ciò lo snowboard e ho messo il piede
sinistro davanti e trasmette ho fatto
una cagata
c'è un po mi sto pagando bruttissimo
come si scenda di viaggio aiuto ben ore
ti seguo io
ma se hai capito che di chi li sta in
piedi in giuria
siamo scia la frana di lorenzo che non
ha capito che con lo snowboard in
territori sta in piedi
pregadio frena figlia da marco no no non
l'ho non libici sono gli alberi no no
non lo re dove cazzo ma no no no no no
no loro
basta
via ce la farete armati però si sia
fatto il massimo ma cosa cazzo sentito
arrivare perché i ragazzi vi faccio
vedere come cazzo sono messo per
scendere io vi giuro che questa roba
veramente veloce allora io
fortunatamente non avendo mai fatto
snowboard realtà non è che non ci sono
date ma se vado mi ammazzo perché va
troppo veloce
però so che c'è chi è messo peggio di me
in questo caso vi faccio vedere salvo
saluta saluta se noi camaggi mi ammazzo
io allora ragazzi dovete capire che
questo è il paese più bello del mondo
perché abbiamo sculture di ghiaccio mail
discoteche all'aperto
harry potter sotto effetto di hashish
cosa fiera in quella porzione harry come
riparano i cellulari montagne li faranno
così
guardate
la qualità di questa riparazione come
nuovo il vostro telefono 21 via cassa di
voglia di merda
sono ormai 11 e mezza poi c'è un quarto
tudor e suri vogliono fare una corsa per
arrivare fino alla casa quindi lascia la
telecamera sasha e corrono verso da casa
allora vi guarda e fa
noi facciamo la stessa cosa leonardo fa
3 2 1 via
ripartiamo tempo 20 metri ha fatto un
volo una strisciata ad almeno cinque
metri per terra si è distrutto ogni
singola parte di mani e ginocchia bello
andare in montagna ragazzi che sono
ormai
bene
si no